diabolical behavior
good morning britain's weatherman alex
biersford is opening up about pierce
morgan's decision to quit the show
following their heated on-air debate
about meghan markle
pierce spouts off on a regular basis and
we all have to sit there
and listen 6 30 to 7 o'clock yesterday
was incredibly hard to watch on tuesday
the 55 year old journalist
made the decision to leave the morning
show after viewers
and his co-host slammed him for his
comments about meghan markle
following her tell-all sit down with
oprah winfrey
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
says meghan markle i wouldn't believe it
if she read my weather report
and the fact against our royal family
i think is contemptible the feeling to
piers
is quite simple over here in britain
he's a bit like marmite too you either
love him or you hate him
but pierce he dishes it out he's got to
be able to take it too
i think there was quite a lot of
surprise when he took his mic
off and stormed out the studio today
after getting a bit of a talking to you
or
dressing down from his weatherman later
that day itv
the network behind good morning britain
released a statement announcing pierce's
decision to leave the morning program
got a good chat with itv and we agreed
to disagree
and on thursday alex weighed in sharing
a lengthy statement on twitter that
explained pierce's departure
wasn't the conclusion he was hoping for
alex said that he knew their opinions on
the treatment of harry and megan were
different before they even sat down
but he hoped they could reach a place of
understanding
quote i didn't want him to quit but i
did want him to listen
alex concludes his statement writing
that pierce has been supportive of him
and given him advice along the way and
for that
he was grateful quote i wish him well
i believe in freedom of speech i believe
in the right to
be allowed to have an opinion if people
want to believe meghan markle
that's entirely their right i don't
believe almost anything that comes out
of her mouth
this all comes after piers spoke out on
wednesday about his decision to quit
i think the damage she's done to the
british monarchy
and to the queen at a time when prince
philip is lying in hospital
is enormous and frankly contemptible
so uh if i have to fall on my sword for
expressing an honestly held opinion
so be it he is has had a lot of stick
over um what many i think perceived to
be his
relentless bashing of harry and megan
and you'll see if you follow him on
twitter friends just
will often tweet just leave them alone
what piers is an argument is no
they don't want to be left alone they're
putting themselves in the public eye
and you know i'm going to go for them
and he and he has done repeatedly